[Music]
hello how are you I am salt and jaramillo with
the most outstanding headlines for
today Tuesday November 17 more
test sites for detection of the cover avn
this week around the valley of the
lord es have near martin luther
king iii lake mead will be available  today
from 8am to noon
while watching venturebeat courier in
technical what will i do at rikers drive
near the ranch begins with
testing thursday afternoon and
friday morning
later clark county leaders will
discuss how to deliver
$300 million awarded
for coronavirus shock relief funds
this
money must be used through the end of the
year clark county plans to invest these
funds in more testing and
helping nevadians affected by the
pandemic
you are looking  good job it happened
inglis from resorts world is already
available online so there you could
find a variety of  jobs for
the resort are looking to hire in various
areas the hotel clarified that it plans to create
6,000 jobs and now we move on
with the weather forecast we will have
some breezes for this afternoon with a
sunny and clear sky around 76
degrees the winds will return tomorrow
that they have  One fine day I came out from
Jaramillo and this was his short
newsletter on yuste out in Spanish
[Music]